Output.
Master Bruce, your greatest fear is...
Snakes?
No.
Clowns?
No, it's being a part of a family again.
No, now it's snake clowns because you put that idea in my head.
Sir, you need to take responsibility for your life...
...and it starts by raising the young orphan you adopted.
I thought I was being sarcastic.
Hello, secret camera!
What? It's the Bat Cave!
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh!
Look, it's the Bat Sub!
Don't touch that.
The Bat Zeppelin!
Don't touch that either.
It's the Bat Kayak!
Do I get a costume?
I love it,...
...but these pants are just a little tight.
I got an idea.
Rip! That's better.
I can only look you in the eyes right now.
Hi Batman.
No way!
Come catch your greatest enemy.
Superman is my greatest enemy.
Superman's not a bad guy!
Then I'd say that I don't currently have a bad guy.
I am fighting a few different people.
I like to fight around.
Let's go defeat the Joker.
We're going on a family trip.
I can wear my costume too.
Well, luckily for us, you left your costume back at...
Rip!
Oh, no, under your clothes.
That's perfect.